Russia has announced it's suspending the
deal that allowed grain to flow from
Ukraine to countries where hunger is a
growing threat a Kremlin spokesperson
says Russia is terminating the Black Sea
grain deal it was put in place last
summer to ensure ships wouldn't be
attacked coming in and out of Ukrainian
ports the Kremlin says the suspension
will remain until its demands to get its
own agricultural shipments to the market
are met
I am so sorry to say that today Russia
has refused to prolange this table
and this is something very serious that
will create a lot of troubles to many
people around the world
we from our side we will do everything
we can through our solidarity Lanes in
order to make available the Ukrainian
grain for the people who eat from it
I have to blame Russia for this decision
completely unjustifying weaponizing the
hung of the people suggestions
foreign
as a tactic as a political tactic as a
military tactic
which it should not be used and I think
non-extension of the Black Sea grain
deal would mean that there would be
less availability of food grains in the
global Food Market they will be less
availability of food grain for actors
such as the word food program to be able
to procure food at the right price to
support the humanitarian needs for
countries that are reeling through
multiple humanitarian crisis